it's important to keep an eye on the
things
that administrations do in the waning
days of a presidency barack obama did
many things in the last days of his
presidency
george w bush also did and one of the
things
that the outgoing trump administration
did is on december 1st
they rolled out their new citizenship
test
for new prospective u.s citizens
why did we need a new test well we
didn't but the trump administration
put one in place and not only is it
filled with right-wing bias it's also
riddled with hilarious factual errors
legal errors historical errors
they can't do anything right in spirit
nor
by the letter so for those who aren't
familiar with this test
anyone not born a citizen needs to pass
an
oral test to become a citizen to become
naturalized
20 questions you have to pass 12 and
that's a 60 correct answer rate the new
test is filled with questions about most
things
about things that most people born in
the us as citizens don't even know
specific questions about
alexander hamilton the trump
administration has put in questions
about the 10th amendment
which most people know nothing about and
it's clear that the idea is to just make
it more difficult to become a
naturalized citizen and in order to do
so
you have to sort of buy into a bunch of
right-wing trumpian propaganda
some of them actually say these new
questions
that the correct answer is something
that is just factually wrong here's an
example
question who does a u.s senator
represent the study guide says
said the study guide says the correct
answer is
citizens of the state now this might
seem obvious
but senators represent all people in a
state
it includes permanent residence as an
example now this is clearly
an anti-immigration type of answer
senators don't represent illegals
now in some ways senators do represent
undocumented immigrants but even without
arguing that
the correct answer can't be all citizens
because permanent residents
here legally with green cards have
representation from senators so it's
it's factually wrong
here's another wacky question from
trump's new citizenship test
what are three rights of everyone living
in the united states
and you can choose from freedom of
expression freedom of speech freedom of
assembly
freedom to petition the government
freedom of religion the right to bear
arms those would all be acceptable
missing is the right to a lawyer the
right to due process the right to equal
protection
the right to freedom from unreasonable
search and seizure it just those are not
listed as acceptable answers
the right to bear arms which is listed
is not absolute felons as an example
are limited in their right to bear arms
but the right to due process
is completely missing it's a factual
joke
and then one more for you what is the
supreme law of the land the study guide
says the answer is
the u.s constitution this is utterly
insane the law of the land includes
the constitution all laws statutes and
treaties that we have
and that's even in the constitution the
constitution
says that the full law
includes statues and laws statutes
not statues statutes laws and treaties
trump couldn't even pass this test let
me put it a different way even
trump couldn't pass the bogus test
they've created even as they delineate
the right answers
and trump also couldn't pass the test
that we had up until december 1st
this is really horrible and it's sort of
a uh
um it encapsulates so much of what is
wrong
about the perspective that is espoused
by this administration now
the good news is this is something that
joe biden
should relatively quickly be able to fix
once he takes office
and i hope that he will let me know your
thoughts i'm on twitter
at d pacman and we'll be back right
after this